yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Peregrine 64 absolutely no
recall any games I've played them quite
a number of times but don't remember
anything so we get a piece already
system here specifically hanging pawns
yarn IBG seven or nine eight six now is
the usual way to play this however here
hmm let's see pawn takes Knight h4s is
very good can also try that here but
probably not as great iam 9hy mean just
rather want to have 94 you write
beautiful I can also play Bishop h3 here
that could be interesting yeah let's do
that little bit unconventional but ask
some question ready for 94 they're also
taking a seven
well I'm quite happy here this position
looks looks pretty good yeah some
pressure now on these six okay yeah both
look good them Knight takes is also good
move 495 pretty pretty awkward this
position if you ask me so night f5
already on let's do it we should see
eight I might have not G seven but not
g7 we can probably take on age three and
that isn't so clear and threatening 25
now some okay I have it your queen nah i
agree 25 was a pretty big threat or a
[Music]
now some things that that went quite
wrong I mean so one takes takes your
black also can take with the I can take
with the piece today with a pawn pawn
takes the night h4 is the problem now
I'm taking this and all night oops sorry
on 9 p-6 jumping into f5 doesn't look
great yeah he decided to play this and
I'm not sure that this is the right move
on it Bishop wave 3 i'm i can switch
but you ate three is kind of awkward
yeah the engine likes this warm yeah it
makes some sense quad kill him what is
the issue here it takes now a 66 takes
and then 27 well okay okay okay I
understand this and it actually this
move okay so i have to play something
now okay then this is a good idea
Queenie 7 a good tactic yeah net is that
the point is that yeah there's a queen
hanging here so I have to do it
differently yeah that's a lot better
than a sixth and now after this is
already quite awkward it took Bishop c5
my life father and this is now a node
easy our thinking we should see eight
even though this looks like there could
be some tactic is night h6 okay that's a
strong move now probably winning or this
one they're definitely winning allow 30
english should have six and made camp
already critical but that that ignored
simply the the basic idea now our
betters g6 according to the comp it now
before he's going to plate well played
that may be on a good day it looks so
threatening anyway so i didn't check all
that there is it is this looks strong
yeah we cannot take it that's clear and
hear something like that feels excellent
very good yeah ok guys thanks for
watching
you